I'm sure three gigs and I got hit a
night that's a lot of fucking drivers
you get door don't look killing someone
isn't crazy Rhode Island was always fun
and then what Kennison when I first met
Kennison out at the store I said oh my
god it was like a rebel
I'd never seen anything and I've seen
everybody I said this is I'm beside calm
I you gotta see this fucking guy he's
not Smet it's unbeliev he's like this
preacher does comedy it's insane and so
uh we bring him to Boston and Imaginext
this is the first stop fired I had to
fire him after the first show why he
showed up all fucked up and you know I
got him some blow and he went onstage
okay just it's doing like new material
yeah and I said Sam is there any way you
could do your HBO he goes don't bro
that's been done that's been done and I
go what I gotta let you go he goes I
figured that then I got him a gig at the
connection then he got fired from there
then yeah out of a place in Malden he
got fired then he shows up at stitches
at my gate and he comes walking in like
awesome man hey yeah I can't lose this
gig this is Mike this is my big money
gig do you trust me
do you trust the beasts they trusted
bass free me I'd say ladies and
gentleman only summon the HBO Saturday
live is one of the best I've ever seen
sampled it out would have a bottle him
away chugs it down burps and says
someone's fucking me tonight and from
then on he found all the room down and
by the end of the night they had hide
him to come back to do the back room at
the paradise and it was off and running
but oh my god is like 86 yeah yeah so
we're in New York and we're doing
Caroline site and I mean everybody
everybody comes out to see the show it's
unbelievable and they're gonna do
Rolling Stone he's on the cover of
Rolling Stone and he's supposed to do
today's show okay so he he flies in
every girl that's ever broke up with him
and puts them all up in the same hotel
different floors I got home
and I told the story the more than the
small group of people but we're in the
room and I'm lying on the side of the
bed brothers bill his mom's dead Sam's
passed up the chair we've been going for
days and this Sam's mother's Lenny
you've gotta get Sam up he's gotta do
today's show and I go Today Show that's
huge man we can't blow this up and he
was just at the point where he didn't
care anymore I thought so I said Sam Sam
get up get up you got it to this your
mother wants you to do it this is big
for it's great for your career and we
turn on the TV and he's putting on his
fucking let me he's put on his go
and this challenge it takes off and we
awesome we watch explosives I will this
I fucking well there's everyone back too
bad his mother's just gonna hold a knee
and in the forex Today Show we won't be
you know that was a horrible thing to
happen you lose all those shows but you
know I guess she was a teacher you don't
have forget her name he goes and the
kids were in the classroom and don't
watch ok this cake I'm right at that I
mean yeah but he was he was fearless
fearless yeah he was you know I don't
know if you know the story about him but
his brother bill wrote that book brother
Sam yeah and he talked about how Sam got
hit by a car when he was a little kid he
was a normal kid and he gets this
horrible head injury and then all of a
sudden was fearless like that happened
to Roseanne and that happened to him
same exact story hit by a car I didn't
know one personality changes a hundred
percent becomes a totally different
personality and becomes his wild
reckless person habit of both of them
listen you know all these all these uh
these documentaries about him and stuff
and I see people that were on the
periphery edges I mean I was with him
a few years I mean we're bringing up the
ball we brought up the Boston when he
wasn't making a lot of money and might
pay them and he loved it and we became
real good friends and it was uh it was
just a time my life that I never saw
anything like that you know what he
break into the preacher thing with his
little feet dancer I mean and so one
night were up
he started canceling missing cakes and
he missed the University of Arizona and
his his manager goes and he had a big
time Angela they just got him you know
the cover of Rolling Stone all that
stuff and he goes Lenny you got to get
him to the show tomorrow you're opening
for mice okay so Sampras come on we'll
go back to the place and mascots blown
shit and I'm going up to go to the
bathroom I'm he's never gets up to go to
bathroom I smash cup would bring Tampa
and we're doing a show it was the year
that Tampa lost every game the
professional football team and they came
in some big offensive linemen biggest
guys ever seen
can we meet Sam yeah I said these guys
want to meet ya and one of them breaks
out a little blow and Sam goes blows
away knew whoa Jeff takes out a bag puts
it down walks out and they're looking at
my yeah he's not human
we go back to a space and now it's 3:00
in the morning
it's 4:00 in the morning we're supposed
to take a seven o'clock flight I said
yeah but I gotta make that flight it's
eight o'clock flight
it's only an hour out of you know LA to
Arizona there right so so 10 o'clock the
the manager shows up and let me go say
man this is not good look this is a
makeup show you beauty and shellfish and
makeup showed it's sold out yeah he goes
take Lenny would you and I'll be out
father woman so we're in the we're in
the plane and he sister how much time
you got that I said oh how much in
aiding us well you know until he gets
here so I go on I'm supposed to do 20
I'm I'm at about 54 and I'm going man
I'm running and I'm holding him off
you're Sam Sam I go hold them all and I
look over and he's on an oxygen tank for
the mass the big Cody's bring up that
dad lives that dad lab bring up
come on and the place goes crazy crazy
crazy crazy and afterwards we go to some
strip club right and so we're in it
everyone's wild man he's a big star you
know man people can't believe it
so sitting all the strippers come over
and he's throwing money around and
someone throws a can of beer that's it
he goes you guys want to make more money
in a night than you make in a month
come with me and we go about eight of
them come and we get in a limo and we go
back to the hotel
I'm reptile 21 Lizer triggered a meeting
and he goes slutty he goes I know you're
married he goes but in about five
minutes things are gonna change you
might want an oasis because once you
open this door you'll never be able to
close it again and I thought mice all
right brother okay and so I left then I
went back to my room get an extra cookie
from the Doubletree oh yeah by my room
so the next morning I get up and I go
over to the room and I open it and it's
fucking destroyed I get a cab I go to
the airport and I fly back and did his
day I never know what happened it was
one guy magic I mean if you ever listen
it's magic fine because I want to know
what but it looked like it looked like a
bomb what I've shit was broken all of it
up I mean like a trashed place but like
dangerously trashed and and blood and
still still blow left in and ball was I
don't know what happened that night you
know Marc Maron was hanging out with him
back in the day when Mark was a doorman
at the comic strip yeah I bet he's a
young kid yeah he did so much coke with
Kinison that he heard voices for a year
his head was broken he heard voices in
his head for a fucking year and that's
when he sobered up he came to Boston
right after that right yeah that's when
I met him yeah I meant Maron in 88 when
he had just just was trying to get his
brain back online
yeah he was fried they cooked his brain
they were just up for days oh not many
people could run outside shell work well
in Boston and we I think we do stitches
and
we closed I should come out we'll go
over to Lansdowne Street because the
buddy masters running that so now we're
drinking bottles of champagne like it's
gonna go that's it men it's enough we
gotta go
so we leave it's him because where we
going now I don't know man it's this
there's no bars open it's after 2
because you got a no place to go
most place I know that they're folded up
they've been shut down he goes wait a
minute
he goes the limo we had the other night
had boozing oh yeah
call a limo so they call a limo it comes
fully stocked what if I goes never
underestimate my father should happen
them you know it was just it was insane
just not human he's a wild motherfucker
oh sure he changed comedy he really did
oh he changed what comedy was it became
something like before him it was people
telling jokes but he was so outrageous
and when he did that HBO special that
one that he did from the Roxy and on
Sunset I was there yeah that fucking
special changed comedy like it changed
people's idea like when he did that joke
about the homosexual necrophilia what I
mean just I'm at the store one night I
go in and the cops the cops loves him
and there was like about 7 squad guys
out front accomplish don't go up Sam you
go and they're all lined the wall the
steps in water I'll watch him and he's
bombing you know I mean he goes yeah you
don't seem to like me I said don't want
you to me favor
you know when you go home tonight but I
want you to take a piece of paper
napkins something anything Eva and what
you write on it someone in your life
that's past you know a brother or sister
a mother to secret dead I want you to
take that home and I want you to get
home and I want you to fuck he would
leave like 20 or 30 tickets for the cops
in that town wherever we were yeah yeah
no cops would always show up oh that's
awesome
I saw one night we're up in Mitzi's and
he's up there jamming with
Clapton Phil Collins I forget who the
other guy was and would you and they're
on the boy and he's got the guitars and
we're rocking it out right and I'm going
I can't play but I'm on this is insane
and so the cops come he goes Lenny take
care of it so I go up and there's like
three four cars the lights gonna go
what's up I say hey it's you have to cut
it down oh man y'all can't believe it
Eric Clapton sign name was Phil Collins
and the jam oh it's salmon exam can we
meet Sam the cop says okay but you gotta
come up and take a picture with him and
you fuck I said Sam I said see that are
closing it down so he goes up and their
Polaroids that's when they had the
Polaroid cameras on it and they took I
had me thinking the Polaroids and Sam
and the cops and what I'd love to see
those pictures but it was you never know
who's gonna come over there you never
know what was gonna come over that was
just incredible he's the example that I
always give to comics of a guy who was
at one point in time one of the best
ever
oh yeah but then dropped off hard like
he dropped off in a big way just stop
writing too much partying his brother
talked about it in the book mm-hmm he
just it's what can happen like I can't
you gotta respect this fucking thing and
he was just all about the ride and then
also he became very very famous probably
too famous right you know well we don't
outlaws a comedy at the dunes that's how
long over there and he had driven out
with Tamayo to my own Sookie and I get a
call early in the morning
Lenny come quick Sam that I go on so I
go over to the Caesars Palace David Bay
and I just can't wait we kept my tech
take the champagne thing take it out
pour water on me and smile pushing me
out away and said it's just welcome to
Japan Mr Bond come out tomorrow I mean
she was so funny man you know what she
was I really enjoyed her and she was
sweet I worked with her used to work
what at the store a lot you know I don't
I don't know if she's is she still doing
comedy I don't know I haven't seen ever
yeah sure oh she did this is she came up
you know and your country you say I work
miles to school in the snow in my
country
you drop atomic bomb on us great yeah
funny funny buddy stuff man but he was
Oh first time I ever did ecstasy was
they were closing the club that he
started at in Austin Texas I guess we're
all going rah laughs stop yeah we're all
going so he drove I think he drove it
flew down it met him and well someone
comes in and says hey man you gotta try
this is what is ecstasy was yeah man
how much that like the buddy give me all
your guys so we got we're all on
actually I never did next month I was
sitting on a couch with dragged him into
a pub and he starts to float away right
so I mean there's aha so I reach over
and I bring him down some guys what the
fuck you quit touching Sam right on the
show
Simba's Thank You Lonnie
[Laughter]